one time at BCD Tofu House the guy
literally handed us our sundubu which is
like boiling hot right okay and he threw
it like a frisbee
lady
across that's how they serve you food in
Delta now they just hold the tray at the
front of the place
yeah yeah but Bobby tipped him like so
much 100 bucks yeah good form on that
frisbee throw
and I gave him like a lot of money well
you have third degree birth yeah here's
an extra 100 but I always go there you
don't even give eye contact he was like
this yeah I remember my brother and I
went to a Korean place and they made
these like fish cakes right and it was
one of those things where they had all
this menu and then the bottom someone
had written we have fish cakes too where
they bake it in this thing put red bean
but you could tell that they don't ever
make it no one ever requests it but my
brother and I requested it and I rather
than getting the batter out and it took
them like 20 minutes to make it because
they had to turn on the thing and they
were flustered and it tasted like [__]
oh right and we threw it away and we
waited in line and we ordered more
just so that we can watch them what is
your cycle you're like the Riddler dude
[__] weird was that you but the
questions
and my brother and I were like cackling
in line like that that I can get behind
that was so far it's so fun that when
that happened yeah but anyway yeah so I
tip well but I get I get what you're
saying you know I get it what are we
talking about
it's kind of similar to how you when you
get your car from valet at a hotel you
go around like 18 times yeah I do that
too and we just wave at the ballet I
don't know it's a game he likes to play
it's really strange La talk I'm like L.A
I live in New York I don't have a
license you don't you don't have a
license no it's expired I'm gonna get it
again but it was like I don't who drives
in New York I know but you don't do you
know how to drive yeah yeah I grew up in
Chicago I know how to drive how do you
know how do we know that test them right
now that's a good point I mean you had a
license in Chicago I did it expired but
then in New York to like to get your
license uh a new license you have to
have your social security card I didn't
have my social security card and then
trying to get us I mean the whole
process so [__] annoying but I
literally just got my social security
card and just got my state ID so I'm
gonna go I take the driver's test to get
my license again
oh [__] but I don't have to drive just
answer questions oh okay
um that's right you're from Chicago
because your grandfather married Esther
povitzki's
parents oh that's right what yeah my
grandpa's blind he's a judge
so that's it
it's just mad libs
I think I think I heard everything wrong
say oh you heard it right no so you're
your dad a judge my grandpa your
grandpa's a judge and he's blind well
that's how Esther even found out that it
was your grandpa because Esther used to
tell a story about her parents were
married by a blind judge and then you
spoke about your grandpa and she was
like wait a second I think Mateo's
grandpa is who married my parents and
sure enough that's what happened
wow connection I know things just you
know Intercity Riddler dude you've been
blind years old he did yeah did you know
him F5
in general he could have died
actually my so my blood grandfather he's
my adopted grandfather my blood
grandfather is Mexican and
um he had five kids with my grandma and
five kids with another woman and named
him all the same names
I don't know my Mexican family but I am
Mexican yeah oh wow wait they named the
five the same as the other yeah there
were two joaquin's two Lisa then somehow
my grandma got my uncle Jack's name from
Joaquin change Jack that's some Italian
[__] I don't know how she did it hey
Italy
um so yeah uh but anyway so then my
grandma remarried a sicilian my blind
grandfather and he they had two more
kids together when they married Lizzy
blunt then yeah it was blinded five
he got sick at five years ago but how do
you get [__] when you're blind you're
smart okay
cool if I was blind so people who are
blind should just sit at home twiddling
their thumbs that's exactly what you're
saying no I'm just saying me how dare
him
I feel like
also referring to my Nana is just [__]
like you [__]
psycho
oh my god oh my god let's go back I
apologize you know what here's what no
no here's what we go here we go
I'm back okay
how many commercial breaks are you
taking in your head like I'm back all
right I'm back I'm back we're back
everybody I'm here the whole time I'm
here again okay I'm here again and I'm
focused